hey guys my name is Jess McDonald you're
watching games what news and today is
the 29th of July let's up the LGBT
focused game a con game Rex found itself
in a little bit of trouble when one of
its major sponsors backed out luckily it
was indeed ev's to the rescue the
original plan was that the convention
would receive three thousand dollars of
sponsorship funding from publisher and I
asked America and that would cover some
of the expenses for the event
unfortunately the company backed out of
the office stating that they wouldn't be
able to make good on the funding after
the event had already happened in a
lovely turn of events it seems that was
just the dark before the dawn as indie
publishers vault the digital Thomas was
alone creator Mike Biffle and goat
simulator deaf coffee stain studios aka
all freaking awesome dudes have pledged
3 grand apiece to Game X Club TV
advanced warfare now has a story trailer
flushing out the game's campaign mode
the trailer opens with an Abraham
Lincoln quote about testing people's
character by giving them power a very
moody and very manly narrator sets the
scene to the chaotic game world crippled
by a global terrorist attack the whole
thing is pretty heavy on the power
corrupts mantra and ends with a glimpse
of the game's multiplayer mode which is
getting its very own premiere on August
11 collector's editions for the game
have also been announced and they range
from the merch and content heavy 120
dollar Atlas Crow addition to the $80
Atlas limited edition which unlike the
former doesn't include the season pass
but does include digital content for the
game and a new multiplayer map ea may
have done something to get on gamers
good sides today by announcing a new
subscription program called EA access
the program is xbox one exclusive
unfortunately but for five dollars a
month gamers will have access to the
vault a collection of digital EA games
the service is currently in beta for
some users where the games available
include fifa 14 madden NFL 25 peggle two
and battlefield 4 EI says they plan to
add more titles soon another incentive
is that you'll get ten percent off EA
digital
content for Xbox one games through the
xbox one store and you'll have access to
trial versions of EA titles up to five
days before their official release this
will include games like madden NFL 15
and Dragon Age Inquisition your progress
will also carry forward if you opt to
buy the full game after the trial period
as for your question of the day let me
know which publishes collection of games
you would want a subscription for and on
what platform that is it for me today be
sure to leave me your favorite stories
and I will see same time tomorrow